STEPHANIE WONG: Welcome to
"What's New in Networking?"
a series to keep you
up to date with, well,
what's new in networking.
This is Stephanie Wong.
And, today, we'll be covering
our core infrastructure
updates.
We'll cover some new shared VPC
capabilities as well as new MTU
settings for Interconnect.
So, stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Shared VPC provides the
ability for organizations
to connect resources from
multiple service projects
to a common VPC.
This is amazing as it
provides centralized control
over networking resources, like
subnets, routes, and firewall
rules.
And it was great for
VMs with a single NIC,
but it wasn't ideal for VMs
which require a NIC 0 to be
a non-shared VPC network.
This means something like
this was not supported--
NIC 0 would be tied
to the local VPC
while NIC 1 would be
assigned to the shared VPC.
To support this,
customers would have
to deploy proxies to
front-end the instances, which
led to more management
and resource overhead.
With this recent launch,
we now support shared VPC
on a non-default NIC.
Now, you can attach a shared
VPC to any NIC of an instance.
And this eliminates the
requirement of proxies
and gives more flexibility
for VM configurations.
And, now, on to MTU.
MTU stands for Maximum
Transmission Unit,
the size of the
largest protocol data
unit that can be communicated
in a single network layer
transaction.
A larger MTU can bring
greater efficiency
because each network
packet carries more data
while protocol overheads,
like headers, remain fixed.
1,500 bytes MTU is an industry
standard IP packet size.
The default MTU for a Google
Cloud VPC is 1,460 bytes.
As of the end of
2020, you're now
able to increase the
MTU to 1,500 bytes.
While this gave VMs the ability
to exchange 1,500 byte IP
packets with other
VMs, services,
or the public internet,
there was still
a discrepancy with Cloud
Interconnect, which
provides direct
physical connections
between your on-premise
network and Google's network.
Prior to this launch, Google
Cloud Interconnect MTU
was set to 1,440 bytes.
With this new launch, we now
support end-to-end 1,500-byte
MTU support.
Organizations can lift and shift
or support hybrid workloads
with strict MTU requirements.
And that's what's
new in networking
for core infrastructure.
Let us know in the comments if
you think these will accelerate
and improve your Cloud journey.
Be sure to take a
look at the links
below for details and
guides on how to use them.
And stay tuned for the latest
launches in our next category
on "What's New in Networking?"
[MUSIC PLAYING]